Prof: Last time,
I was arguing with you about
some of the novelties that Dante
introduces within the poem at
the start of Purgatory.
One--there's some formal,
what we would call descriptive
novelties: light,
time, the question of time.
There's a moral innovation,
the focus on the connection,
the subtle connection between
freedom and new beginnings.
The idea of freedom as,
first of all,
a political value,
and the meeting with Cato,
so that though insisting on
these novelties and that the
novelty and the new,
or the possibility of renewal
is exactly what's at stake in
Dante's new poetics.
I was also trying to emphasize,
and I think that that came
through,
hopefully with clarity,
the whole tension between the
old and the new,
the pull of the past,
the sense of nostalgia and
whether it's an existential one
or in the biblical Exodus story,
the nostalgia for the time of
safety,
apparent safety in--of the Jews
in Egypt,
even though within--under the
slavery that Egypt stands for.
These were some of the issues
and then we moved onto Canto II
where we specifically,
on the encounter of Dante with
a musician,
by the name of Casella,
where Dante dramatizes,
as if unaware,
as if mindless of what had
happened in the previous canto
and the experience of the
previous canto,
he just lapses into exactly the
same type of predicament that
the previous canto had featured.
Namely, here he is indulging in
memories of the past,
lapsing into a form of
idolatrous self-confrontation.
He's listening to the beauty
and lure of the canto--
of the song that Casella will
sing for him and then,
finally, the presence of--the
eruption of Cato once again who
focuses on the ethical demands
of the place.
Purgatory is a place of moral
purification and so he urges all
the souls that had gathered
around the song of Casella,
to move away,
and the language that he uses
is that of dispersion:
like doves,
like pigeons,
like doves that go on
dispersing throughout the plain.
Clearly what--in retrospect,
what is apparent,
I think, in all of these
situations,
is Dante's insistence on the
power,
on the importance of a communal
destiny, a communal fate.
Though this communal fate
appears as defeated.
Let me just explain what I mean
and then we move on with today's
readings.
In the case of Cato,
Cato has been defeated by the
civil war between Pompey and
Caesar, to the point that he had
to commit suicide.
In the case of Casella's song,
that poem had managed to gather
around itself,
not only Dante,
but all the other souls who had
become mindless of what they
really were supposed to do,
continue their climbing up the
mountain.
And Cato intervenes and he also
shatters the--as illusory that
form of community.
What I think that Dante's after
is the following:
there may have been defeat and
therefore the value of these
experiments in communal
existence,
that of Cato who commits
suicide, and that of the
aesthetic gathering around the
poetry.
They are both partially
defeated, and yet they contain
seeds that will be necessary for
his rethinking about how to
renew and reconstruct his idea
of the common historical
destiny.
This is really what--and I hope
it's fairly clear and we shall
see this a little bit on today.
I turn very briefly now to
Canto V,
for a couple of reasons because
it's--
Canto V, if I had to give a
general title to the canto,
I would say that this deals
with Dante's sense of
retrospective knowledge.
I have been really focusing on
a Dante turned to the future,
as you know,
a Dante who thinks and reflects
on hope,
who thinks and reflects about
issues such as the future in
general,
that this is freedom is--and
time as the future is the real
time.
Nothing else really matters
because everything else can only
be understood as part of the
future,
even when it's past,
with the logical underlying
assumption that that which is
past was once the future,
the only real--the only reality
of time.
He understands in
Purgatorio how time moves
in a uni-direction,
which is future oriented,
so it's really a time as
future,
that it turns out to be also a
return to the Garden of Eden,
but that is kind of second
thought for him.
Here now though,
in Canto V, Dante meets souls
that the--bring to the fore for
him the power of retrospection.
These are souls who manage to
repent at the last minute.
It's almost as if--again,
it's time, it's a question of
time, but a time that is sort of
inexhaustible.
It's always possible to fall
back, reflect,
and turn one's life around.
One figure that he meets,
and this is Canto V around line
90, you shall see in a moment
why I select him.
He meets a figure who is--he'll
identify himself Buonconte da
Montefeltro,
who is the son by the way,
of a man Guido,
whom we met in Canto XXVII of
Inferno,
and this is why I like to focus
on him.
The break between the past and
the future,
the son being always a sort of
statement about a project,
about a future--son or the
daughter--
a statement about the future
and the father ends up in Hell.
The son ends up in this
purgatorial ledge on the way to
redemption,
so there is no chain of natural
necessity and causality between
the past and the present and the
future.
There is a focus on freedom,
because once you break that
bond of necessity,
you are really opening up,
inaugurating the idea that we
are free,
that we are really free to make
ourselves regardless of what
antecedents we may have behind
us.
There is another little detail,
which is a formal--
it really tells you something
about Dante's art,
so here he goes on in line 88
or so: "Then another spoke:
'Pray so may that desire be
satisfied with draws thee to the
high mountain...
" What extraordinary
language about desire drawing
us.
We are--this is Dante's
universe of desire.
We're impelled by desire,
and desire is really what moves
us.
It's love that moves us;
it's desire that impels us to
go one way or the other.
"...
do thou with gracious pity help
mine.
I was of Montefeltro;
I am Buonconte."
And I hope now that you are
sensitive to this temporal,
to the tenses,
the disjunction in tenses.
I already pointed those out for
you in the canto of Ugolino and
here too,
Buonconte is asserting his
identity in the mode of the
present and detaching himself
with the view or the use of the
past tense from the family,
Montefeltro.
"Neither Giovanna nor any
other has care for me,
so that I go among these with
downcast brow.'
And I said to him,
'What force or what
chance,"
or 'adventure' more than
'chance.'
Chance is too heavy a word and
I will come to this a little bit
later where Dante reflects on
the significance,
which has "took thee so
far from Campaldino,
that thy burial place was never
known."
This is an extraordinary scene,
an extraordinary encounter for
one very autobiographical
reason.
The reason is this,
is that Dante fought at the
battle of Campaldino.
It was the moment his great
maturity,
his great entering into the
battlefield of life,
when he discovers that now,
because of the victory that the
Florentines had in Campaldino,
that he also can have claims
about himself,
about his own family,
and political future.
But now he meets a victim.
And there have been those who
go on claiming with very little
evidence,
if you are in a battle--I don't
know how many of you know the
field of Campaldino;
it's pretty large,
about twenty-five miles east of
Florence.
The idea is that--so those who
go on claiming that maybe this
is someone that Dante killed at
the battle,
and now sort of retrieves him,
brings him back--
there's no evidence for
this--but it is a painful
autobiographical moment for him.
A moment where he did
experience violence and he
perpetrated violence.
And this is the answer:
"Ah, he replied,
'at the foot of the
Casentino.'"
Rather than answering the
question of the battle,
he goes on thinking about his
death and recounts his death.
This is a poem about births.
You remember,
I always like to say this about
the event of being born,
and the portentous quality that
being born implies,
the kinds of alterations that
we all can bring on the world
around us by the very fact that
we were born.
Now he talks about death.
"Ah he replied,
'at the foot of Casentino a
stream crosses called the
Archiano, which rises above the
Hermitage in the Apennines.
To the place where its name is
lost I came, wounded in the
throat, flying on foot,
and bloodying the plain.
There I lost sight and speech.
I ended on the name of Mary and
there fell and only my flesh
remained.
I will tell the truth and do
thou tell it again among the
living.
God's angel took me,
and he from Hell cried:
'O thou from Heaven,
why dost thou rob me?"
And so on.
The reason why I'm really
reading this passage,
not only to tell you about this
notion of the power of time and
the power of retrospection,
looking back at that final
moment in one's life,
it's the decisive moment that
confers,
a coherence,
and a meaning to one's life.
We were born,
and we are born with certain
expectations of what we can do,
but death becomes the
revelatory event.
This is really the point of
this passage,
but there's another point.
Dante deploys the same
rhetorical genre of the debate
which he had used in the
encounter with Buonconte's
father.
So that by the sameness of the
rhetorical genre,
you are forced to really couple
them together,
and yet the point is that of
the distance between father and
son,
that of the distance in the
temporal disjunctions between
the past and the present,
and the future.
The canto ends with six lines
which are extraordinary lines,
where sentimentalists as
occasionally I am,
we'll go on even seeing a
subtle allusion of Dante to his
own wife.
It's an encounter with Pia de'
Tolomei,
a woman from Siena,
and clearly this little passage
is meant to refocus--
remind us of Francesca in Canto
V of Inferno.
It's the exact symmetrical
canto.
These are the lines which I
will read, I will go on reading
also in Italian,
you read it in English.
Professor Margaret Brooks was
asking me to give some evidence
of what the Italian language
sounds like,
and so it's a moment of
nostalgia for you too,
I take.
So, "Pray when thou hast
returned to the world and art
rested from the long way,' the
third spirit followed the
second,
do thou remember me who am La
Pia."
It's a sort of--an epitaph of
La Pia,
who was mistreated here by the
husband and yet incredibly
forgiving and the word ends--
and the passage ends with the
word gem which in Italian is
gemma,
Dante's wife's name.
So one wonders if Pia also
doesn't stand the kind of
wishful thinking on the part of
Dante that his wife whom he
had--
because of exile had been
forced to leave behind may also
forgive.
That's the point:
is Dante introducing this
radical category of forgiveness,
which is the true scandal?
If you want to begin again,
then forgiveness is exactly
what's demanded.
Let me read the passage in
Italian and we move on.
"Deh,
quando tu sarai tornato al
mondo,
e riposato della lunga
via,"
seguitò
'l terzo spirito al secondo
"ricorditi di me che
lon la Pia;
Siena mi fé;
disfecemi Maremma:
salsi colui che
'nnannelllata pria
disposando m'avea con la sua
gemma."
Now we move to--after this
highly--I find it a passage of a
great pathos--as all of them
are--great intimacy,
where Dante's really involved.
And just as he's obliquely
involved with Buonconte,
they fought in the same battle
on opposite sides,
and then this encounter with
Pia de' Tolomei.
We turn to a public canto,
a political canto.
Let me just try to explain a
couple of things before we move
on to something that I care
about here, in terms of the
Canto X and XI.
That's how he begins Canto VI,
political canto like Canto VI
of Inferno,
and like Canto VI of Paradise.
You know that now,
it's a principle of symmetry at
work.
This is not--Canto VI of
Inferno is about the city
of Florence,
Canto VI of Purgatorio
is about Italy,
and the disarray,
the chaos, the disunity of the
country.
Here he starts,
"When the game of hazard
breaks up the loser is left
disconsolate,
going over his throws again,
and sadly learns his lesson;
with the other all the people
go off;
one goes in front,
one seizes him from behind,
another at his side recalls
himself to his memory;
he does not stop,
but listens to this one and
that one;
each to whom he reaches his
hand presses on him no longer
and so he saves himself from the
throng.
Such was I in that dense crowd,
turning my face to them this
way and that,
and by promising I got free
from them.
There was the Aretine,"
and so on.
It's an extraordinary simile.
To explain, that's the burden
of the simile,
that all the penitents are so
surprised at seeing Dante alive
in the beyond,
that they all go after him.
He is--there's a throng of
people pressing on him,
that's the simile.
The simile that he uses is that
of the winner in a game of
hazard.
That is to say,
he is the winner.
Dante's the winner and they all
go after him,
and they all neglect Virgil.
Virgil is the loser.
Therefore, the simile
introduces a language which is
extraordinary.
It is as if Dante were speaking
of his salvation,
of the uniqueness of this
journey that he is undertaking,
in terms of a game of hazard.
We all have been thinking that
this is really a providential
journey and now he is casting it
as if it were just a game of
chance.
Here is the word chance that he
uses: hazard.
It's an interesting metaphor,
first of all,
from the point of view of the
language of play.
This is playful.
It's a way of almost of casting
one's salvation as the casting
of the dice.
It's a lottery here that
someone loses and someone wins,
and Dante says,
well I was born after the
incarnation,
so I had the possibility of
saving myself and Virgil did
not.
It's also an interesting
metaphor because it really
introduces the question of play
in Dante's theological
perception,
and it's an issue that I will
talk about much more extensively
when we reach Paradise.
But one thing is clear:
that Dante understands that the
relationship between--
and that's all I'm going to say
unless you press me a little
later but we'll talk more about
this metaphor--
Dante understands that the
relationship between the soul
and God is a relationship shaped
by risk on both sides,
and that this idea of risk that
would seem to be a blind casting
of the dice in effect
constitutes the freedom that the
human beings can have in the
scheme of things.
The whole point of salvation
is, by using this language of
hazard and chance,
is rescued, it's disengaged
from my--
the idea that God knows it all
and we are going to--
we are determined in what we
are doing.
What Dante's saying,
by focusing on a time bound
metaphor,
is that we are engaged in a
risky relationship and as in our
relationship between God and the
soul,
there is this element of danger.
That's it, that's the metaphor.
To make it more precise so you
don't--
you know where I'll be going in
the days ahead,
whenever in antiquity,
they would discuss--
mainly Boethius is the most
important author--
the relationship between human
freedom and God's foreknowledge,
they would always present the
case to say that God is outside
of time,
always says being outside of
time.
All times converge in God,
and so that God sees all things
in the present so that should
really--
God is here,
it's a point of view which is
transcendent and therefore
synoptic and we are in a
diachronic world:
past,
present and future,
but everything is at the same
time.
We think that we live in a
world where we do not know what
tomorrow may bring us.
Whatever decisions we make now
have already been--
what kind of consequences,
whether they're unpredictable
or they have been determined by
things that escape our control,
but God knows.
And this is the Boethian scheme
of harmonizing God's
foreknowledge and human freedom.
It doesn't take too much to
realize that this is really a
little bit of a delusion,
because either I'm free or am I
not free.
It may be that God knows it
all, but it doesn't mean that He
wills that I do what I do.
He knows but He does not will
it, and yet, He knows and I'm
here and I don't know,
so my own freedom is still a
little bit rhetorical.
Dante does it differently:
it's a departure from Boethius.
The relationship between God's
foreknowledge and the souls
being in time is one that
introduces the question of
chance and hazard,
and that involves both God and
the soul.
To be very precise,
he doesn't say it here,
and that's why I hesitate to
get into that.
I would like to work with the
text to make this very clear.
The issue is that in a love
relationship between God and the
soul, we are always at risk.
If you accept the principle of
a love economy,
regulating the universe,
which Dante does,
certainly does,
then you understand this notion
of hazard in--
not as a principle of just
chance in the sense of casual
blind randomness,
but in the sense of this
risk--proposition risk element.
Then the canto goes on--this
particular metaphor goes on with
another meeting between two
poets.
Yes?
Student:
What do you mean by love
economy?
Prof: The economy of
love--the question--the
clarification is what do I mean
by the love economy?
Dante's universe,
it's a universe of love and
that's how creation takes place,
the creation of the universe
and the creation of human
beings.
So we are--the involvement that
we--every soul has with God is
one of love.
Just as in the relationship
between say, Beatrice and Dante,
there is an element of risk in
loving.
What is that risk in loving?
I can think of several.
I think we are all grown ups to
understand that,
one loves and one may not be
reciprocated in love.
That's a pretty bad risk.
Certainly, it's a risk of God
who creates and may not be
loved,
which is the story of what
disobedience is,
and certainly is the
existential experience of human
beings to be involved with
someone.
Either we love the wrong
person, then we say wisely I was
loving the wrong person?
I'm being ironic with that idea
of wisdom or discovering that
indeed in every relationship
there is time,
feelings change,
we have so many ways of
thinking about it.
There is a--Dante's response is
look,
he likes figures--we shall talk
about this--
like Francis who goes to pray
on the cliffs at night because
he wants to dramatize the idea
that even a prayer puts you at
risk of being hurt or not being
hurt,
of being disappointed,
of discovering that the world
does not go the way you want it
to go,
and that which is true in
prayer is true in love.
That's all I was saying.
I wasn't saying anything more
than that.
In Canto VI also,
the political canto,
there is an encounter between
two poets.
One is Virgil with Sordello,
who is a Mantuan poet.
They all share the same
birthplace, Mantua,
across the centuries.
They meet and the very idea of
Mantua,
they ask Virgil,
Virgil starts saying,
"Mantua--"
clearly playing with a famous
epitaph,
I think, the line interrupts.
There it says:
"Mantua made me,"
the famous epitaph written
on--in Naples where Virgil is
buried.
"Mantua made me and the
south, Calabria,
took me away.
I sang the arms,"
the Aeneid,
"the herds,"
the Georgics,
and the story about the
Bucolics,
"the fields."
It's just--in two lines the
account of his whole life.
So he starts saying,
"Mantua."
I think I'm alluding to this
birthplace--once again the
birth--and Sordello and he
embrace.
This embrace,
this existential encounter,
this other little moment which
is insubstantial,
because they can't really
embrace.
They're spirits,
another failure after the one
that we saw with Casella in
Canto II of Purgatorio.
That triggers Dante's political
invective against Italy.
It's the moment of--which I
will read very briefly.
I mean I will not read the
whole thing but it's an
invective--the kind of civic
sense of responsibility.
"O Mantuan..."
This is line 75 of Canto VI:
"And the gentle leader
began, 'Mantua";
and the shade who had been all
rapt within himself,
sprang toward him from the
place where he was,
saying: "O Mantuan,
I am Sordello of thy
city."
He's a Provençal poet,
but he wrote in
Provençal and from
Mantua.
"..
.the one embraced the
other."
Look at this phrase,
which is extraordinary because
in Italian,
now I feel that I can
read--thanks to Margaret I can
read Italian as freely as I
care,
e l'un e l'altro
abbracciava.
I'll return to this
construction in a moment,
"the one embraced the
other."
It's a phrase of reciprocity --
one embraced the other -- the
reciprocity of affections across
time.
Dante begins his incredible
vituperation,
his attack against enslaved
Italy and look:
"Ah,
Italy enslaved,
hostel of misery,"
a number of metaphors,
"ship without pilot in
great tempest,
no princess among the provinces
but a brothel!
So eager was that noble soul,
only for the dear name of his
city,
to give welcome there to its
citizen,
and now in thee thy living are
never free from war and of those
who one wall and mote shut in
one gnaws at the other."
Another line that seems to have
a sort of grim version of the
reciprocity.
Earlier one embraced the other,
now one gnaws at the other.
If you look at the Italian,
it's really slightly different.
The English doesn't give
that--this translation at least.
Line 82, in te non stanno
sanza guerra li vivi tuoi,
e l'un l'altro si rode.
One has a reflexive form,
the other one does not,
and the moment of violence
Dante uses the verb "si
rode" in the reflexive form
in order to imply that the
exchange is an exchange that it
always turns on oneself.
One knows that the other for
oneself, therefore it reverses
and denies the reciprocity,
the action of reciprocity
indicated by the previous
phrase.
I could also emphasize a couple
of details here,
where Dante says:
"to give welcome there to
its citizen,
and now in thee thy living are
never free from war and of those
whom wall and moat shut
in."
It's a very--you do know that
the word for community,
which we always use,
community--it's a word that
etymologically comes from the
Latin for wall,
moenia.
Community meant,
and stems from,
a concept from the sharing of
walls, houses,
piling, and built one on top of
the other.
That's the idea of a community.
The shared walls of the city,
which here is now seen
as--viewed as separating one
from the other.
This will continue with the
lack of laws and the families,
including the Montague's and
Capulets,
for you Shakespeare lovers,
who are mentioned here,
and then Dante ends up with--on
line 125 with a returning to
Florence and a little--
clearly bitter satire.
"My Florence thou mayst
well be at ease with this
digression,"
I'll come back to this metaphor
in a moment,
"which does not touch thee
thanks to thy people who are so
resourceful."
Dante talks about Italy but it
turns to Inferno VI with
the invocation of Florence.
He's calling this poem,
this invective,
a digression,
which literally means that it
does not belong in the poem,
that Dante is stepping out of
the economy of the poem,
and talking in his own voice.
It's a digression.
That's what we call a
digression, right?
You use a particular language
that doesn't really belong to
the general plot and theme,
but then the meaning of this
digression is made really clear,
later, when he says,
"which does not touch
thee."
How ironic.
Of course he's saying literally
in this digression,
you are so much better than all
these other towns.
That's the irony:
Florence is no better,
therefore this digression
doesn't really concern you.
It can also be understood in
another way, in another more
tragic and more sinister way.
This digression does not touch
you: my language will not affect
you.
The whole statement in all its
ambiguity becomes one of the
reflection on the impotence of
the poetic language to affect
the historical--
the unfolding of history,
the ordering of the city.
It is as if Dante,
were, here, that the
relationship between the voice
of the poet and the political
order is one of inevitable
rupture.
Dante tries to improve and
change, that's clearly the
thrust of the passage,
and the thrust of the invective
also declares the powerlessness
in his doing so.
We are doing very well with
time, so I have a chance to read
a little scene.
Dante moves on talking about
the first night of
Purgatorio will take
place and he takes refuge in the
so-called Valley of the Princes,
where a new garden,
another garden is going to be
described,
which in many ways fulfills the
garden of Limbo in Canto IV of
Inferno.
Dante has these motifs that
keep reappearing and here it's
more than a natural beauty of
the place it's--
there are precious stones
implying that though
Purgatorio is the world
of transition for transient
souls,
there is something abiding
about this place.
Then Dante moves on,
I want to read a paragraph here
with the meeting with the
princes.
I want to read the first
passage which is the--an evening
song.
Dante's--Dante the pilgrim now
is taken with nostalgia for his
hometown.
It is the pilgrimage of desire,
which is the poem,
the poem of desire,
desire for God,
desire for Beatrice,
now turns into the desire for
the comfort and the shelter of
the home he had lost.
Listen to this passage,
it's written in many ways
in--along the lines of
Provençal poetry of
nostalgia.
Listen to the assonances as
you--the first six,
seven lines of Canto VIII,
listen to the assonances the
chiastic structures of the
sounds of which I'm not going to
point out to you,
you can do that on your own.
Era già
l'ora che volge il disio
ai navicanti e 'ntenerisce il
core
lo dì
c'han detto ai dolci amici
addio;
e che lo novo peregrin
d'amore
punge, se ode squilla di lontano
che paia il giorno pianger che
si more;
quand' io incominciai a
render vano
l'udire e a mirare una de l'alme
surta, che l'ascoltar chiedea
con mano.
Then here, I'm not going to be
able to read it,
but to tell you how the poem
should be read,
then they go and hear a hymn,
a medieval hymn,
Te lucis ante
terminum,
which, if we really had the
time, I would come to class with
the whole Latin hymn because
we--
Dante gives only the first
three words but clearly we are
supposed to hear the whole thing
about the dangers of the night,
the sense that the night is
fraught with phantasms and that
they will intrude on the powers
of judgments of the various
souls,
Dante's own included.
With Canto IX,
Dante moves from--as he does in
every Canto IX,
marks the rupture from a
particular area of the poem to
another.
Remember Canto IX of
Inferno and the encounter
with--failed encounter with the
Medusa, the passage into the
City of Dis.
Now with Canto IX,
Dante moves into Purgatory
proper, and so we'll go with
Canto X, XI, and XII.
We're not going to be able to
do all three cantos today,
so I will return to some of the
things that I will say now about
Canto X and XI that I hope to
cover.
How is Purgatorio--where
is this purification proper
going to take place?
This is the ordering.
Dante will go these so-called
seven deadly sins.
I don't know that you know what
they are,
but the first one we shall see,
the first one is--
they go from spiritual sins,
pride is the root of all sins,
to lust at the end.
In every representation of this
sin,
Dante precedes it with a
representation of its opposite
virtue: so that we have humility
in Canto X,
and then in Canto XI punished
pride.
First of all,
as if Dante has to learn that
which he's going to witness a
little later.
In a sense, it's the absolute
reversal of the economy of
Inferno in
Purgatorio.
You may remember that I said
last time that the incredible
quality of the structure of the
poem is that Dante wants us to
see experiences of evil in
Inferno first,
so that when we get to
Purgatorio and
Paradise,
we really have the chance to
appreciate what the good is and
appreciate what the absence of
the good may be,
but evil really generates and
engenders.
Here now, he changes all of
this.
In Purgatorio,
he starts with the
representation of the virtue of
humility and then the sin.
The representation of the
virtue of humility takes place
through the language of art.
Dante approaches the cliff and
on the sides of the cliff he
sees three sculptures embodying
examples of humility.
The word pride,
which in Italian is--we have
the English "superb,"
in Italian, we call it
superbia.
To the word "superb,"
you add -ia,
which is pride.
The word humility in Italian is
the same thing as
umiltà.
The word humility means--comes
from the ground,
the sense of being down,
of being--the idea that one is
really with--
let's say--the feet on the
ground.
The very opposite of
superbia which implies
some kind of immoderate flight
away--
a sense of the view of the
overman,
the idea of being a superman.
It's the idea that someone who
wants to transcend the
limitations of this world and
being human.
The word for humility and the
word for human have the same
etymology, in case you wonder
where it comes from.
The homo,
which means 'man' in Latin,
comes from homos.
We are called man,
human beings,
because we come from the earth
and we are close to the earth,
and we return to the earth.
We come from the earth and
we're returning to the earth.
The idea of humility is the
same notion.
There is a kind of implicit
connection, etymologically,
between the two words,
the two terms.
One more remark to make,
this whole idea of having--
a couple of remarks before I go
on with the text that will serve
you for the rest of
Purgatory.
The idea of having the virtues
and the vices,
first one and then the other,
seem to cast Purgatorio,
but it's not really that way,
as a variant of a medieval
poetic form called
psychomachia which means
"the battle of
thoughts."
By the way, this is a Latin
poem, one of the early Latin
poems by this Latin Spanish poet
called Prudentius.
It's a kind of
psychomachia,
the battle of thoughts,
of contradictory thoughts.
The second thing that I have to
say, is more important for the
poetics of Dante.
Keep in mind that the whole
poetic mode of
Purgatorio,
unlike the poetic mode of
Inferno, is played out in
Purgatorio through the
imagination,
art images, memories, phantasms.
In other words,
we are really in a world which
is in between that of bodies and
souls,
the world of the middle ground
of the imagination,
and now we have the world of
art.
A world of art,
that Dante says,
and I read from Canto X,
at the very beginning.
I just want to give you this
as--it's an extraordinary--I
don't want to go into excessive
detail, but I have to do it this
time.
"When we were within the
threshold,"
Canto X,
the very beginning,
"of the gate which the
soul's perverse love
disuses."
Purgatory is all a sequence of
variations on love.
That's the moral law of
Purgatory.
All sins in Purgatory are
sins--either we use the--
we give love to the wrong
object, or we love too much in
terms of what--
how we are being loved back or
we love too little.
These are the three general
subdivisions of Purgatory.
That's "perverse love
disuses, making the crooked way
seem straight,
by the resounding I heard it
closed again;
and if I had turned my eyes to
it what excuse would have served
the fault?"
The reflection of what happened
before: "We were climbing
through a cleft in the rock
which kept bending one way and
the other,
it goes around the
mountain,"
that's really what the language
is,
"like a wave that comes
and goes,
when my Leader began:
'Here there is need to use some
skill in keeping close to this
side or that where it turns
away."
The cliff is--there's an abyss
underneath it,
so it's an invitation to
prudence along the way.
"..
.and this made our steps so
scant that the waning moon had
regained its bed to sink to rest
before we were forth from that
needle's eye.
But when we were free and out
in the open above,
where the mountain draws back,
I weary and both uncertain of
our way,"
we know now this has become a
sort of formulaic expression of
the uncertainties of this exile
as he moves up the mountain,
"we stopped on a level
place more solitary than a
desert track.
From its edge bordering on the
void to the foot of the lofty
bank which rises sheer would
measure three times a man's
body,
and as far as my eye could make
its flight,
now on the left hand,
now on the right,
the terrace there seemed to me
the same."
What is all this about?
What I want to point out is
that Dante is measuring the
whole landscape in terms of the
measure of a human being.
He's using the human beings--a
human being as the measure.
Is man the measure?
You have heard that expression,
right?
Are we the measure?
Are we the measure of what,
creation?
Are we the measure of what we
should do?
This is exactly the point of
the canto because pride means an
inordinate love and belief in
our own excellence.
Pride means that we do not
think that we are--
we can be measured by others,
that we want to become the
measure for others,
or that we really do not belong
where others may think we
belong.
That's what pride is.
It's a sin, very common.
Who do you think you are?
Who do--don't you know who I am?
This is the language we use and
it's pride--I always like to say
that we are never really proud
when we are dealing with our
janitor.
They are not proud;
we've become so human, so good.
We are always proud with those
who endanger our sense of our
own measure, who seem to take
their own measure of us.
Dante is starting with the idea
of measurement and I'll come
back--this is the crucial
metaphor and I'll come to that.
How do we measure what is human
and that is not human?
One thing is clear:
that pride, superbia,
means an inordinate love of
one's own excellence.
We are really far superior,
we think, than anybody else
would have thought us.
Then he goes on looking at
images made on the white marble,
"such that not only
Polycletus but nature would be
put to shame there."
Extraordinary metaphor already
talking about measure and about
order, these are works of art
produced by the hand of God
directly.
God is an artist and God has
made these images,
but it's such that nature,
which as you know,
is the daughter of God and the
mother of the arts,
and also an artist,
the famous Polycletus,
a Greek scholar,
a Greek scholar Polycletus,
would be put to shame.
Already there is this sense of
rivalry within the pattern of
generation of arts.
That's the first thing,
and then the first image that
we see, is the image of the
angel Gabriel,
the messenger who came to
earth, that's humility.
He came to earth,
the descent of the high
becoming low,
while the human beings who are
low want to think of themselves
as very high.
"The angel who came to
earth with a decree of the
many-years-wept-for peace that
opened heaven from its long
interdict appeared before us so
truly graven there in a gracious
attitude that it did not seem a
silent image."
That's God's art,
but very clear,
there's no difficulty in
understanding this art.
"One would have sworn,
he said: 'Ave,' the first words
of the angel Gabriel doing the
Annunciation.
The Annunciation is the story
of the humility,
whereby obliquely,
God becomes man.
So that's the descent,
another form of,
not only the humility of Mary
in accepting the mandate,
but also the idea of the
descent.
By the way, let me just point
out that this 'Ave' is
what we call a
boustrophedon--
I have spelled the word out for
you--
for 'Eva.'
It's very conventional in
medieval literature:
the idea that Mary becomes the
one who reverses the role of
Eve.
With Eve there is the loss of
the Garden and the Fall,
with Ave there is now
the turning of the key,
as it were, and the Redemption.
"For she was imaged there
who turned the key to open the
supreme love,
and in her bearing she had this
word imprinted--
this word imprinted:
'Ecce ancilla
Dei.'"
She acknowledges her--
Mary acknowledges her ancillary
role.
She is a servant and she
acknowledges herself as a
servant.
Now, along side with this,
what we could call an ethical
education, Dante has to learn
what humility is.
There is an ethical education,
learn about what this humility
is about.
There is also an aesthetic
education going on,
simultaneously.
After all, Dante's really
looking at art.
The question is what is the
relationship between the virtue
and art?
How can the two be together?
To give you an idea of how
complicated the problem is,
in the next canto Dante goes on
meeting all the painters.
You read Canto XI,
Giotto and Cimabue,
who are emblems of people who
invest their productions with an
inordinate sense of its value.
Then Dante puts himself--puts
his friends Guido Cavalcanti--
you remember the two --
Guido's, Guido Guinizelli,
one Guido removed the other
Guido from its nest,
and now the third person has
come, meaning himself who
probably will rout both of them.
What a proud statement.
It is as if the artist is
always prone to this sort of
inordinate idea of who they are
and what their value may be.
So art and humility and pride,
this is the issue.
The ethical education and the
aesthetic education.
What is the aesthetic education?
Virgil is telling Dante how to
look, that's really the most
complicated thing.
For those of you who are doing
art history, that's really what
it's about.
How do we look?
What do the eyes really reveal
to us?
"Do not keep thy mind only
on one part."
That's the looking--the belief
that we--or the temptation to
lose sight of the totality of
things and not--and just taking
one part for the whole.
"Do not keep thy mind only
on one part,' said the kind
master who had me on that side
of him where the heart
lies," on the left,
"so that I turned my face
and saw beyond Mary on the same
side as he that prompted me,
another story set on the
rock."
Dante has to learn how to look
and what he's looking at are
stories.
Story, the word is Greek,
for those of you who know some
Greek.
It comes from 'I saw and I
narrate,' and it's the same
etymology for story and history.
This is a little bit of
allegory of history,
we are saying.
As if Dante's really
telling--begins with the New
Testament,
the story of Mary,
now we're going to see a
picture from the Old Testament,
David dancing in front of the
ark and then an episode of
Trajan,
the emperor who is an example
of humility.
You shall see him in a moment.
The point is that the whole of
history is an allegory of
humility and that's God's art.
That's what Dante has God
represent for us.
"...
Mary..."
etc."..
.There, carved in the same
marble were the cart and oxen
drawing the sacred ark on
account of which men fear an
office not committed to them.
In front people appeared and
the whole company,
divided into seven choirs,
made two of my senses say,
the one: 'No,' the other:
'Yes, they sing';
in the same way at the smoke of
the incense that was imaged
there, eyes and nose were in
contradiction with yes and no.
There the humble
psalmist,"
David,
"went before the blessed
vessel girt up and dancing,
and that time he was both more
and less than king;
opposite, figured at the window
of a great palace,
Michal looked on,
like a woman vexed and
scornful."
This is really the story that
is told in Samuel,
in the Bible,
and Dante's really
reinterpreting it for us.
So I beg you to really pay a
little attention to some of
these episodes.
First of all,
David is humbling himself.
He's dancing.
He lifts up his ephod,
his dress, and starts dancing
out of joy.
It's an episode that is used as
one of the many cases of
so-called ludic theology,
playful theology.
Its intrusion is that--in the
plan of salvation there is
always the presence of this
comedy, this comic idea and
David embodies that.
Then there's this little phrase
which we--you must have noticed
that appears so often in this
canto.
More often in this canto than
ever before in the whole poem,
"more and less."
It is as if it's impossible to
use or find in a canto where
measure is the issue,
the position about where we
are, who we are,
and what we are doing.
One thing is clear;
that opposite to David,
there is his wife,
Michal, sitting at the window,
a different perspective.
What she sees,
this is art,
this is a question of
perspective what she sees.
She is so angry at David
because he, by his action of
dancing in front of the ark,
is humiliating himself.
He's losing his state as king.
He's losing his stature as king.
The fact is that for Dante,
Michal is completely missing
the point.
It is a stance of someone who
thinks that she's superior,
a stance of someone who's
sitting at the great--
at the window of her great
palace, who will not have
anything to do with what's below
her.
We are entering the world of
the--the domain of what pride
may be, what's wrong with pride,
and why pride may really be a
sin.
Pride may not be a sin because
we want to reach higher than we
are.
That's probably okay.
What makes pride a sin is that
we tend to have contempt for
what we think is below us.
That's really the displacement;
it blinds us.
So--I'm introducing here,
since this is a world of art,
the notion of a perspective.
We've been talking about
perspective.
Pride is tied to perspective,
because it sets--
by being proud I think that I
have,
within myself,
I certainly have a view of
myself that may be at odds with
the reality of me.
Certainly, this is the case of,
not David, but it's the case of
Michal, his wife.
The third episode is,
I think even more interesting,
and then we'll see what's going
to happen.
"I moved my feet from
where I was to examine close at
hand another part of this,"
how do you examine?
What is an aesthetic education?
How do you look at the images
at hand?
"another story which I saw
gleaming white beyond Michal.
Depicted there,"
now the third episode is from
secular history,
Roman history.
So you have the Old Testament,
the New Testament,
the Roman secular history,
"there was the glorious
deed of the Roman Prince whose
worth moved Gregory to his great
victory--
I mean the emperor Trajan;
and a poor widow was at his
bridle in a posture of grief and
in tears.
The place about him seemed
trampled and thronged with
knights and the eagles on the
gold above them moved visibly in
the wind.
The poor woman among all these
seemed to say:
'Lord avenge me for my son that
is dead, for whom I am
stricken';
and he to answer her:
'Wait now till I return,"
he's going to Romania,
Dacia.
If you see the column of Trajan
in Rome, it's still the
monument--document of that
expedition.
"..
.wait now till I return';
and she: 'My Lord,' like one
whose grief is urgent,
'if thou return not?';
and he: 'He that is in my place
will do it for thee';
and she: 'What shall another's
goodness avail thee if thou art
forgetful of thine own?'...
'Now take comfort for I must
fulfill my duty before I go;
justice requires it and
compassion bids me stay."
It's the story of Trajan who
gets off his high horse,
levels with the little widow.
The diminutives are Dante.
The language is of humility,
the little widow,
and administers and gives her
justice,
because for Dante,
the perfect emperor in Trajan
certainly is the perfect emperor
must be--
must have the attributes of
mercy and justice and he gives
evidence of that:
"if for whose sight,"
etc.
Now that's the drama that now
develops.
Dante's seen all this,
he has understood these images
and the meaning of these images
and--
I'm just going to tell you
about this little drama and we
stop here.
"While I was taking
delight,"
no problem in taking delight.
After all, this is God's art,
so having delight in itself is
part of the appreciation of this
art--"..
.the images of so great
humilities,"
I think that the oxymoron is
deliberate,
"so great humilities,
dear to sight,
too, for their Craftsman's
sake," I love them because
they were made by God.
Virgil prompts him,
"See on this side many
people, the poet murmured,
'but coming with slow steps;
they will direct us to the
other stairs."
Now here is Dante's drama:
"my eyes,
which were looking intently,
were not slow in turning to him
being eager for new
sights."
He yields to the temptations of
the eye.
Have you ever heard about the
three temptations?
The pride of life,
the pride of the eyes and the
curiosity and the pride of the
heart, but I would--and the
three temptations are present
here.
"But I would not have
thee,
reader,"
Dante's turning to us in an
apostrophe,
as he has done before,
"fall away from good
resolve for hearing how God
wills that the debt be paid;
do not dwell on the form."
He's telling us not to care
about the images as such
"of the torment,
think of what follows,
think that at worst it cannot
go beyond the great
Judgement."
He sort of is making a
preemptive strike.
Don't worry about the peculiar
form of the art,
look at the meaning of the
art--and he can't--but that's
what he wants us to do.
He says--look at what he says
to Virgil: "Master,' I
began,
'that which I see coming to us
does not seem to me persons and
I know not what they are,
so confused is my sight."
What an incredible contrast
between what Dante had seen with
God's images,
all clear to him,
but now that he's seeing some
human beings who are doubled
under massive boulders--
because that's the punishment
inflicted on the proud,
to put them and press them
against the earth--
he does not recognize them.
It is as if his aesthetic
education has been for nothing.
It is as if ethical education
has been for nothing.
He had no difficulty in
deciphering God's art,
which is so clear and luminous,
but now he does not want to
identify with what he sees.
He resembles Michal,
who from high up,
does not want to have anything
to do with David.
This is the--exactly the same
problem that Dante is facing.
He has--he had no problem with
Gabriel,
the descent of Gabriel,
he had no problem with Trajan,
but he himself is unwilling to
identify with those that he
believes are beneath him.
Then he goes on.
Virgil explains,
"The grievous nature of
their torment doubles them to
the ground,
so that my eyes at first were
in debate about them,
but," he says,
they are really human beings
like you.
Dante goes into a further
apostrophe to all Christians
calling himself superbi,
in Italian, cristiani.
The Italian line is actually
very interesting for a reason
that I'll tell you in a moment.
Look at line 121,
O superbi cristiani,
miseri lassi. ..
There is an incredible contrast
between the word superbi,
meaning superior,
right, a claim of superiority
and the word lassi which
means lapsed,
having fallen.
So within the same line you
capture the two--
this dynamic of how we want to
be up and how we're going to--
the more--the higher up we want
to go the quicker we seem to be
falling.
"Weary wretches,"
mistranslation,
"who are sick in the
mind's vision and put your trust
in backward steps,
do you not perceive that we are
worms born to form the angelic
butterfly."
I want to stress this shift in
pronouns, 'do you not perceive,'
Dante is literally taking the
higher ground.
We do not know, he knows, right?
Do you--he's preaching to us,
''do you not perceive?'
But then he--with a subsequent
pronoun that we are worms,
he literally erases the
distance between himself and the
readers,
between himself and the other
Christians.
He places himself on the same
ground where we are.
That's the quality of the
double voice of Dante,
systematically punctuating this
text,
as claim of a transcendent
superior perspective,
because after all,
he really has seen the whole--
the unfolding of God's cosmos.
He really has witnessed it,
but at the same time,
he descends and is part of a
common plight.
That's really what the line is,
"Do you not perceive that
we are worms born to form the
angelic butterfly?"
It's an allusion that the word
for butterfly,
not in Italian,
but in the Roman sarcophagi,
in antiquity,
whether they are in
Aix-en-Provence,
if you happen to go there,
or you go to Fiesole,
where there was a Roman
cemetery, you would always see a
butterfly imprinted on the
sarcophagus because the Greek
word for butterfly is psyche.
It's the same word for the soul
and the butterfly,
and by putting the emblem of
the butterfly that indicated at
death the soul finally would be
capable of flying off toward the
light and toward the creator.
So Dante's clearly using and
remembering this kind of motif
that he has seen.
"That soars to judgement
without defense?
Why does your mind float so
high, since you are ..
.imperfect insects,
like the worm that is
undeveloped."
The language of a metamorphosis.
We are in the process of making
ourselves both alive and in the
penitential world of Purgatory.
And then how he ends with a
kind of iconographic motif that
recapitulates the whole
iconographic element that make
up the poem,
Canto X, "As,
for corbel to support ceiling
or roof,
a figure is sometimes seen
joining the knees to the breast,
which begets from its unreality
real distress in him that sees
it,
in such a posture I saw these
when I looked carefully.
They were indeed bent down more
and less as they had more and
less on their back,
and he that had most patience
in looks seemed,
by his weeping,
to say: 'I can no more."
What is this about?
What is this story about?
Well, the story is first of all
about this passage.
It's about the fact that Dante
has just warned us not to pay
attention to the form and to
look at the meaning of the
particular message.
Now he returns to us and
focuses on the form.
What he's describing are the
so-called Caryatides,
human forms,
that if you go--maybe in New
York you may see them,
but certainly in European
cities these human forms seem to
be buttressing edifices and
buildings and they are
decorative,
but Dante is saying,
the form matters.
We cannot really go to the
ultimate meaning by bypassing
the form.
He's literally,
by picking up the sculptural
motif of the canto,
returning to this idea.
We shall see as I have to leave
you hanging on this problem of
perspective.
Next time, we'll read XI and
XII and continue,
and therefore the meaning of
art, how art can change a moral
perception of the world.
That's the idea in which you
are all wondering--have been
wondering with your questions.
What is Dante's understanding
of art?
It's so dangerous and it can
be, of course,
but there is a role that art
can play in altering our
perception,
our moral perception,
in an effect form becomes a way
to go to understand the moral
world and the moral terms in
which you are.
We shall see this next time.
Let's see if there are
questions now?
The real--I think we are
approaching the heart of the
matter in Purgatory.
The relationship between ethics
and aesthetics and what I really
pointed out so far,
then is this idea that Dante is
trying to find out what is the
measure for human beings,
because you cannot say well,
it's pride.
What criteria?
If I want to reach for what is
so far away from me,
why should that be viewed as a
sin of pride?
What are the criteria?
What is the context in which we
can really talk of pride and why
is humility any better?
We haven't touched any of this
yet.
One thing that is clear is that
Dante is,
for now, on the one hand,
giving examples of art and
humility,
making mistakes,
the confusion of his
perception.
He says that he cannot quite
figure out what are these shapes
that he sees.
There's something disfigured.
He cannot quite identify with,
he cannot recognize them and
then claims that we really
should be looking at the
meaning,
at the ultimate meaning of
things, but then he returns and
valorizes the idea of form.
We cannot bypass form in art or
in experience.
We cannot skip the idea of
time, that's really what
existentially it amounts to.
That's all I really have said.
Then, maybe,
I explained to you a few
etymological connections:
humility and the human,
the meaning of history,
and introduce this principle of
perspective that I have been
talking about before.
This is really connected with
the representation of art.
Perspective,
what is the--what kind of
perspective does art then give
us?
We all know that in art,
we use perspective,
especially the modern language
of art,
the modern language of
painting, ever since the
fifteenth century explicitly
discusses the question of
perspective.
I see the world according to
the position that I occupy in
it,
and the position that occupy in
it reveals things to me which
are unique and irreducible.
At the same time it implies--it
also implies--but this is not
the case, the possibility of
manipulating space.
The fifteenth-century
Renaissance discovers that space
is not unalterable and fixed,
but it can be manipulated.
We're dealing with--up to that
point, maybe we're dealing with
time and the manipulation of
time.
You don't have to watch a
football game to know what I
mean about the manipulation of
time, but then there is such a
thing as manipulation of space.
I can create the space.
I can make of a small space
something appear large.
Space is not a fixed entity.
That's what perspective comes
to mean in the fifteenth
century.
For Dante, perspective is
connected to an inner world.
What is my perspective of
myself?
What is my sense of the measure
of things?
How do I view the world?
Michal gives one answer,
and she can be angry about what
David does, misunderstanding the
whole point of David.
What does she misunderstand
about David?
That in humiliating himself,
he had really found himself
higher by the idea of
humiliation of self,
which is exactly that of Mary,
and which is exactly that of
the story of Trajan.
How do you--Michal does not
understand the reversibility of
positions.
That's really the argument,
so far and I think that Dante
is making a big deal with pride
because pride is seen as the
root,
the spiritual root,
of all evils.
Let me see if there are some
questions that I can--we have a
few minutes--please.
Student:
Why does Dante have trouble
sympathizing with the sinners in
Purgatory,
or other people when he doesn't
have trouble doing the same in
Inferno?
Prof: In Inferno,
why does Dante's trouble
sympathizing with the sinners in
Purgatory?
Especially here,
because in Inferno,
he even kicks some of the
heads.
You can't--I mean he has
sympathy, but when it's
necessary he just--he has had
it.
And in Canto XXXII,
the guy was frozen and stuck in
ice, it wasn't pretty.
But here it's true,
especially now he has--he
declares this--his confusion.
It may be because I couldn't--I
did not know what these forms
are.
I think they have to do with
the whole question of what did
he learn,
first of all,
from the images that he saw
because you know Virgil had just
taught him how to look.
Look here;
you move around;
don't stay in one place;
you can look underneath,
so that's one problem.
What is a moral and an
aesthetic education?
Then he's just also,
I think, indicating the whole
idea what--is it ever possible
to look at the world?
More of this next time,
as disengaged spectators.
Think of ourselves in the
theatre, which is an image that
I probably will bring in and
discuss.
You go to the theatre and you
really--
sometimes we all feel that we
should jump on the stage and
rescue the damsel in distress or
whatever,
and yet, you may see someone
who can do that,
but many of us won't.
We want to be unaffected by it,
that's what Dante's doing.
He would like to be--to feel
that he is no longer like any of
these sinners.
That's the mistake he's making.
It's really that he's--it's an
indifference coming to him from
something akin,
though not exactly,
to Michal's sure sense of
herself.
I have nothing to do with the
mob here.
What is this? This is the king?
I don't want to even be his
wife.
That's what Dante's doing in
that scene.
I do not want to be with this
kind of disfigured lowly forms
of life.
I am better,
I have seen God's art,
and I have learned about God's
art.
Do you see the moral and
spiritual confusion that this
kind of drama is going to
generate in him?
That's the answer.
The one who reflects
beautifully on this,
I will bring the passage in,
but I would like you to read it
if you can.
Book II of the
Confessions of St.
Augustine, because St.
Augustine loves to go every--he
doesn't like to go to the
spectacles at the Colosseum
because they are so vulgar and
beneath him,
but he loves to go to the
theatre and he has an
extraordinary reflection.
What does it mean to be
unaffected in the theatre?
How do I have to understand my
discomfort at the theatre?
It's the very image Dante uses
at the end of Canto X.
You remember when he says that
we see Caryatides,
which we know are phony,
and yet they can inspire some
kind of distress.
I'm paraphrasing very poorly
the last paragraph,
the last lines of
Purgatorio X,
"Is it possible to ever be
indifferent spectators of the
turmoil around us?"
What's at stake when I say,
well these things don't touch
me, have nothing to do with me,
and Dante's saying,
they always touch us.
It takes time for him to
understand it and I think that
he is unveiling that.
He's showing it to us in Canto
X.
Please.
Student:
You seem to draw a connection
between form and time
sometimes...
Prof: I think that we
can draw a connection between
form and time,
and continue,
you want to make a reflection
on that?
Student:
Then also if there is some way
to draw in the notion of
futurity as time at...
Prof: The notion of?
Student:
Futurity or--as time necessary
at the beginning.
Prof: Yes.
Student:I'm kind of
struggling with the idea of an
art form which is sort of like a
fixed immutable thing and I have
no idea...
Prof: The question is
since--
I think that was implied,
if I didn't say it in what I
was saying,
that there is a connection
between form and time.
The struggle--the question then
becomes we are usually--think of
form as something which is
fixed, how can that be part of
the world of time?
Well, in a number of ways,
I would say.
That the form--Dante is saying
first of all,
witnessing or watching history,
therefore it has a kind of
unfolding and he discusses art
in terms of a metamorphosis,
an ongoing process of change
that includes the idea of time.
One way in which Giotto really
differs from shades from what
we're going to see next canto--
it's not an arbitrary relation
here that I'm making--
distinguishes himself from
Byzantine mosaics is that he
introduces a history.
Painting is a series of
elements and you got to keep
looking at all of them.
So it's a form for all--it's
unalterable quality the form
indicates;
forms change,
there's a history of forms to
begin with.
I could become generalized in
my answer--Dante understands it
in a way as a metamorphic
sequence.
From that point of view form
sense of all time,
in fact, Dante says whenever
you see a particular scene,
avoid what you are seeing and
see that what it means,
now that is the occlusion of
time.
That is an eclipsing of time.
Let me just go to the ideal
lesson, the ideal poem,
it's like when you are reading
a poem.
You're reading a poem,
of course the form is
unchanging,
but unless you know the
beginning, and you start from
the beginning and you read
through,
i.e., time, you,
come to the end;
you miss the point about the
poem, right?
I mean I do.
You got to read--you got to be
in time and the novel,
you got to read Proust,
forget it.
Pulci, which I'm reading now,
that takes forever.
So thank you;
we'll see you next time.